well do the emergency evacuation
announcement if I may so please know
that the meeting will be audio recorded
should be required to evacuate doing
would you please leave the room by the
door to the fire escape staircase which
is behind those shutters there please
hold both can browse in case the stairs
a little slippery if anyone is unable to
use the stairs will they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape door where they can
then be given assistance or assembly
point will be in the public car park at
the side of the Civic sweet please do
not delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings and please remove to return
to the building until given to do so by
council start ok apologies for absence I
don't believe we have any is a right
direction thank you non members
attending there are none I would like to
introduce if I made Nicole Nicole would
be that's right those a deputy 15 while
effectively but actually is that right
yeah it's just so thank you and your
Delise for today Sony yeah so you know
total size of these but this is nicole
right so thank you very much for coming
on tonight you're very welcome and it's
in the meeting here on the 4th of
November is it your we are you happy
that's an accurate record they do agree
that I sign was a true record right
receive declarations of interest if any
anything should arise during the meeting
that you notice please raise it at that
point the night we made right item five
matters referred to the executive and
reports from other committees there are
none so we go straight to 96 which is
the quarter to financial management
reports
thank you I suppose in right Simon
please it does take this forward first
and what were asking you to do with this
report is to note the report subject
which will make than me it's submitted
for Council for approval the scale of
movement of certain budget headings is
the reason why needs to go to 24 council
what we're trying to do is consolidate
under spends and savings within budgets
so that we can go forward at the end of
the year knowing more precisely what
we've got reserve in reserves and what
are spending has been within the very
home the the items printed in dark are
the actual recommendations and they're
spread through the report at some 16.4
and sick 21 on 6.6 was also one small
amendment at the bottom of page six
point six five point four we're in the
last paragraph where it says appendix
three we should say endless to
the reports been with you a few days we
haven't have any questions put to us but
we'll quite happy to take any questions
tonight should you happen ok thank you I
mean it's good to see the savings that
have been made your the projected
savings at the end of the year and I
think that's a credit to our south and
to executive executive members that
they'll actually identified that and
taken that through to do me some hero
and ah sorry you know it was just on
page six point three it might come up
before with obviously I wasn't at the
run Legion it's on bullet point on the
recovery plan removal grounds
maintenance contingency 50,000 is that
going to be an issue at all it's a
contingency that spin that but not being
used on previous years so rather than
just having it sitting there when it's
not move acquired please and thank you
chairman and she's our hands like lemon
home page six point two since the report
was probably put together community
safety now falls under my portrait thank
you any other points and winter winds
made as i say i think is a great piece
of work this is to be recommending for
councils
council as far as recognized as a
concern i assume they're all carried yes
and if there's no other comment i'll
take you forward thank you very much
your name again right so item seven this
usually I think you will baileywick
again Simon but although so choke me
mrs. Cheney that's it so don't really
care I'll read that one who carries
thank you again and you were able to
throw your voice show okay thank you
callie and well basically we had we've
looked at three options for this item
option one was to remain and twenty
percent which was a no-go really an
option three was to increase to
thirty-five percent which i think
certainly for my personal property on
him was going to be too high and an
option to was to increase it to
twenty-eight percent and when we look at
our main breeding authority
we've got part of our twins proposed LCD
is at thirty percent chance what is 23
cultures to 20 f in 25 Arlo 24 more to
20 and souls 28 South m25 tendrán 23rd
25 and other school 12 15 so really I
think we sit in a reasonable position
then fine justify me in West 20 so sort
of caught by the little brown / right
any comments please anyone notice we've
had the concentration coming through
this asana figure and i think it's it's
worth notice fine 7.1 says that
potentially 1700 people could be
affected by this we do need to remember
that binds nature we've potentially
within that group got some of our more
disadvantaged and vulnerable residents
and we do need to make sure that the
whole council sport mechanism and the
partners that we work with to support
our residents are aware of this so that
should there be any issues they simply
don't go and notice because of the
nature of the people it's impacting them
and there's am on 20,000 reserves for a
discussion area called ship fund which
is available for those who are in real
need so it has to be noted as well okay
any other comments please footnote
please share later 8.3 so this is normal
because the chance have decided to give
us the viewer the potential changes with
tax credit systems wrong plates in our
favor 8.3 as an expungement you'll take
seven points ignacio's 45 7.6 i am it's
a pen seven boys exchange paragraph i
went through five or seven point six
seven x 6 paragraph in of the effect of
here also notice don't you yeah chinese
to the tax credit for some budgets via
how are we get out sorry yeah and thank
you very much gently so i had to read
the paragraph sorry okay thank you very
much kayla any others please did you
want say just just to confirm chairman
that recommendation 1.4 his
recommendation need to call council yeah
rather the resolution decision yeah ok
so this decision we recommended and
chancellors pointed out to me quite
right either one point for this is
recommended to counsel the city a
minimum income for the self-employed
persons without the oct s we kept my
cool 16 in live alone welfare at all
they've never happy with that I agree
great food thank you much so I ain't
there is he
think back half days to the next channel
oh we didn't have a great take up on
them playback ruling but as you can see
from the report we have had more
compliance this year but looking at the
chance is nothing particularly serious I
think in view of the fact that most of
our departments if not all are very lean
and effective starting obviously the
work and has increased their workload
isn't raised and particularly concerned
about any of these certainly with with
competitors with disaster fastest acid
by understand because obviously they are
under pressure I think really we are
where we are mostly still got the
membership as I have your same roof as
well it was very useful tool for us yeah
as far as out you know putting policies
for disconcerting consultation we do so
that's that's quite handy thing for us
as well but I mean this report is just
for noting and I think the idea is to
have this on a regular basis so that we
can see trends coming forward and
even problem areas that may arise and
hopefully yeah we need live in the bud
as soon as we possibly can we have had a
member chairman if I my silent and
wanted things to be put under complaints
such as if if the if Zeta drops and the
magic rubbish in the street and left it
there and I resident that span are
complying that isn't it in a plane and
it's just a matter that you just ran out
the council and suitable to send someone
out to clear its right away that SAT and
I've seen it happen and you know they're
all contacted by found etcetera mobile
so in my opinion that doesn't need to be
what does a complaint okay well I think
he's really down to the resident if they
want to love it as a complaint but I
think it would be you know the lobby
chose to conduct life because they you
know they they do work extremely fast
and very efficiently they're having said
that of course I should really dropping
anything coming forward ticularly the
system that we have this is a very clean
ecosystem and I think when I think of
other councils where they have plastic
bags that are ripped open by those these
cats dogs whatever or blown by the wind
you know I think our system is extremely
close nothing bro lucky for our
residents in my opinion to have that as
carry it forward anyway that's that
point any other points please mention
miles de question please do under the
heading service error which is probably
the area that I would for orcas own
bathroom analyses patient guy sorry 8.8
and 48 or 50 you're on the
so if you look at the chart there we
look timeliness service error policy to
satisfy the staff and other the service
error element column I would generally
be concerned about and I will probably
want to look at the detail especially
the three complaints about under the
Democratic section is that just people
plan politics yeah I mean and it's
difficult with some of these will be
classes service errors but it isn't
generally in somebody it hasn't had the
service that they would have expecting
they want to come make a complaint about
that so you know we do have the details
of that around service episode some of
these they are different kinds of
service areas if you lie sometimes if
somebody has complained twice and that's
definitely a service area and as a
counselor were saying with anything like
the litter dropping litter we do always
actually put those into our back office
system among them if someone comes back
again and says that still hasn't been
collected that goes down as a service
area so for those types of things that's
what they cannot envision to complain
against Democratic I just don't
understand so you if you could possibly
put there to me I'd love to know what
verse 30 mm Oh 18 never gets anything
promise bonus or Ares p for the green
right that's how no one is a complaint
against it's not certainly rely on him
anyway yeah okay thank you for that I
Larry other questions please so members
done report
you right then I'm going to rings is
crumpled paper there right so my foot
forward these cruiser resolution members
of the public we've come to the end of
business will be up there on our members
of the public in the right now so but it
turns out it's right we consider that